first one is if you had to go on a road
trip who would you choose as your
companion now you want preyas
you can literally like lift buildings
yeah but I can do that so I don't need
someone else hook me I've seen you
struggle with pencils this is versus the
GameSpot show that pits your favorite
games consoles franchises and hot burn
issues against each other this week is
the Battle of the PlayStation exclusives
as we put the new god of war against the
Last of Us fighting for God of War is
two more Hussain who over the course of
play the game has started to model his
facial hair on Freitas's big bushy beard
great big bushy beard and arguing the
case for the Last of Us is Oscar Deus
who despite weirdly looking the spit
image of at Reyes is actually the
offices biggest fan of Naughty Dog's
masterpiece
each you're going to argue the corner
for their game over the course of three
randomly picked topics with the overall
winner being decided by you the
wonderful viewer last week's tightly
fought battle between Far Cry 2 and Far
Cry 5 saw Oscar claim his third win with
52% of the vote for his far cry 2
arguments can it be stopped yes yes he
can we're going to be throwing up a
clickable poem rights here on YouTube or
if you're watching over on GameSpot calm
let us know who you think has won the
debate in the comments section below
right enough from me let's get into it
[Music]
alright you prick Warwick I'm good thank
you oh you I am the God of War even
though it's a terrible game it's not a
terrible game it's a very good game it's
not as good as the last of us and I'm
gonna prove it to you alright first
topic of discussion is your mum it's
actually characters okay the Last of Us
has amazing characters not only are they
strong and have their own
characteristics and their own
personalities but you see them grow over
the course of the game for example Joel
isn't a particularly likeable person he
does a lot of things that I disagree
with but every decision he makes I can
understand why he made it and I think
that's why I like playing as him even
though I don't like it when it's and
it's the same with Ellie everything she
does in reaction to Joel I would feel
exactly the same he's telling her that
she's too young or whatever she's like
no I can do whatever I want I am strong
enough and like I would react in exactly
the same way and in fact I frequently do
with you as my boss not only that you
see them grow together as well
throughout the game and they don't
really know each other and that's a
really smart move as well because that
means that you don't really know Ellie
to start because you're playing a stole
and Joel doesn't really know her so you
empathize more with Joel in that way but
then by the end of the game they've
spent almost a year together through
that you feel you've grown closer to
both of those characters in the same way
that they've grown closer together as
well almost pretty much 99.9 percent of
that is also true of a trace and his
father Kratos they're two characters who
are kind of estranged they're father and
son he needs to get close to his son and
they grow and you see well how they come
together it's exactly the same sunny
Santa Monica have obviously taken huge
amounts of inspiration from it Ellie as
a character does develop but it's always
in one direction but at Reyes he grows
like a kid would grow
he has moments when you think that I'm
getting through to him he understands
now but then something will happen and
it'll kind of reverse and you realize
he's if he still doesn't have that
experience I think what makes God of War
stand out is that relationship but also
the fact that a key participant in that
relationship is a character that
everyone wrote off as a character Kratos
he was this OneNote superhero type
character who was always angry that was
the joke and it
a character that everyone wrote off and
provides an incredible amount of depth
and new perspective on him it
revitalizes the character and it does so
without like cutting off his history it
embraces that and it shows that those
three games where you're killing gods it
has an impact on you as a person and the
way you explores that explores it
through how you guide your son and that
whole journey is some of the best video
game writing I have seen in years
I agree like from what I've played of
God of War it does to use his pass to
good effect
but as someone who hadn't played
previous god of war game he is kind of
unfair don't you think to say oh well
he's got loads more history and texture
in his that's essential to it though
like the last verse is the first in the
series right and I think I think you can
play God of War on its own and see the
context you get to be at Reyes when you
don't have the knowledge because at
Reyes is a character who doesn't know
his father's history he just knows that
this person is like kind of closed off
and so you get to be as well as playing
as Kratos you get to experience his
history and learn it drip feed it
through essentially stepping into the
issues of at Reyes well I've worked with
you for 18 months now and I've learned
the you like Kratos or an angry man who
I hate and like Kratos when cameras off
I'm gonna rip you to shreds and then
throw you into a ditch and forget you
ever existed
and maybe I'll salvage some herbs from
you or something okay so the next topic
is combat so the old god of war games
that servers are created as Westerners
again we can do combat check this out
and for me I was like now you can't
really for today this is the game that
shows that actually Western developers
can do super satisfying really really
rewarding combat and what I love about
is it manages to do it without
sacrificing what was good about the
original god of war experience it still
has the heft like the way I think of it
is like imagine Gears of War you know
the heft that you had when you were
playing Gears of War for first time it
does that translate into like a platinum
game style character action game the
combat fundamentally from the very
outset is satisfying partly because when
you hit things it feels so good
everything is chunky like you the sound
effects the feedback is so good but
mostly because that weapon that you get
the Leviathan axe is one of the coolest
things that has been in
using a videogame they've made a God of
War game which doubles up as a 4-game
you throw a thing and you could when it
comes back it hits things on the way
back so you can figure out how to
properly use that you throw that ax if
you hit them in the head it freezes
people into place the strategic
considerations it adds like they keep on
coming it's super super satisfying you
still have things like you know your
Spartan rage which just powers you up
and you feel like a god when that thing
happens I agree with a lot of what you
said they're actually like I think God
of War has memory during satisfying
combat cool moving on but but I think
the reason I prefer the last versus
combo which is obviously very different
it's a very different style of combat
the last versus combat is grounded in
reality
so that is translated as obviously it's
guns and hand-to-hand combat rather than
you know magic axes but those guns feel
real and part of that is to do with the
fact that the characters feel real as
well so joel has a wavy aim like he's
not a really perfect fighter because
that's not who he's meant to be so
obviously there's stealth from the rest
of us which is very different to most of
war you know you don't play the last of
us in stealth because you prefer it or
because it's more fun or because you
don't want to kill anyone
you play it because you need to and I
think that grounds the combat in reality
it makes it so much more tense than God
of all where god of war is sometimes
difficult but you always feel so
powerful even from the very beginning
where it's the last of us you don't
really feel that powerful and I think
that tension is so exciting and makes it
so exhilarating when you succeed the
relief when you manage to get away is
amazing and that's why I think the last
versus combat is better than so my
counter to that is that all exists in
God of War as well it's not difficult to
find just requires you to step away from
the you know the main path and explore
one of the situations I had was I
climbed this small tower and walked into
this arena and this dude is an armored
dude he was super powerful but I had
just unlocked a rune if you dodge at the
very last second everything slows down
and you've got a very few brief seconds
of win a window to hit attacks so I've
got footage of me fighting this guy
where it's just ducking every single
swipe and doing like one or two hits and
then getting it's like a non-stop
half-an-hour fight and it was one of the
most exhilarating
combat scenarios I have
in quite a few years and it would played
like a Dark Souls fight as well like I'm
so bored of you talking about Dark Souls
and just talking in general you're gonna
I think I've thoroughly proved that
cover based shooting is well old and
boring and provides nothing new my
dude's got a hammer he's got a sword oh
shut up he's got an axe sorry he throws
it and then he calls it back next topic
is shut up
well building I definitely think the
Last of Us has the more impressive world
in its fiction everything about the
gameplay feeds into the world that you
find yourself in so obviously it's this
meant it's meant to be this harsh
environment where zombies are crawling
about and you can't really go anywhere
without running into them and but the
mechanics feed into that as well with
stuff like you don't find ammo very
often and that sort of reinforces the
fact that this world is really harsh and
so much of the last verses storytelling
is done through its environment as well
and it's world and that's obviously
manifests itself in stuff like the notes
that you find in houses of letters to
loved ones and stuff like there's this
amazing thread of an entire community
that you sort of follow their journey
through the sewers they lived under
there and you you follow the journey of
this one guy who's trying to find this
community and then he finds them and
then they're living there and they've
got children and they've got a play area
and it's they're happy and then it
documents their downfall and then
getting killed none of that is shown to
you you just read about it and it tells
you things subtly and then you're you're
left to infer what you want to infer
about his environment and so it sort of
borrows from books in that way of like
it doesn't tell you everything and you
can use your imagination and I think the
way it does that is sublime that's fair
I like the world in the Last of Us quite
a bit what I like about the worlds of
God of War is again it doesn't force
loads of story or world building on you
it's something that it rewards you with
when you explore and it's not just like
small notes or stuff that it has that
but it's also like the way communities
look when you go there like you go to an
area and you can see that a battle has
been waged here
it also teaches you so it's set in Norse
mythology which means Odin Thor Loki
it's that but it's also not that it
doesn't it like in a grim fairy tell us
kind of way like we live in an age now
where Thor is a an Avenger and he's like
this you know Paragon of good and like
he's so nice in the world of God of War
Thor is an absolute [ __ ] like he is
a [ __ ] and like the game shows you
that gods are benevolent all the time
and then it also like explores mythology
in such a cool way so like the kid at
Reyes what you're doing is you're this
the work the way it builds the world is
it's the kid learning about his kind of
like culture more and then explaining it
to you so like that's a really
interesting bit of world building this
Greek god is around and everyone is not
okay with it because this guy's got a
reputation for tearing people apart and
killing gods so you can imagine how like
all those worlds collide into this weird
mishmash of different cultures and
characters and odds against each other
it's just a really like overwhelmingly
dense story but one that's so good to
pick out for hours and hours and hours
and it keeps giving you more and more I
mean in all seriousness I do actually
have a lot of respect for the world that
God of War builds and I think there are
a lot of similarities between that world
and the world of the Last of Us and
therefore I think we should end this
debate here and just let the people
decide because at the end of the day
these are two excellent video games yeah
this is like a GameSpot 9 out of 10 it's
a tomorrow saying 10 out of 10 this is a
solid 7 are you right that's clearly a
10 I don't know shut up I missed story
of your life in a point-blank open goal
you could not miss it somehow it was
good to miss misses let us know if you
think Oscar has missed the mark with his
argument by voting in our poll or if
you're everyone Gamescom put your
thoughts in the comment section down
below
it'll be your vote that decides who wins
so make yourself heard now is the time
for this week's quickfire round a series
of dumb fun questions written by the
rest of the UK team naturally Taman
Oscar haven't got a clue what they're in
for
all right you floppy head first one is
if you had to go on a road trip
would you choose as your companion 100%
preyas
are you joking Jolie is miserable
yeah we're not Joel he's [ __ ] Annie
but that becomes very clear with you
yeah I'll take Ellie yeah hey you want
preyas
you can literally like lift buildings
yeah but I can do that so I don't need
someone else to kill me
you may I've seen you struggle with
pencils boy what what meal would you
cook for your games characters like it
doesn't even have to have any froze to
it they're just a lot of meat for
Crayolas all he wants yeah he's very
much a cardboard make sure he's like
fully protein DUP who would win in a
fight between a trace and Ellie at Reyes
hands down that dude is savage yeah he's
pretty savage I don't know if it le is
very strong Ellie could definitely beat
me up under there most people can be you
I mean I've seen gusts of wind that
almost have taken you out who would you
want as your dad's kratos or gel gross
is god it's very simple it's really easy
yeah be so angry though he'd like it
Connor telling you or cuts or crows nuke
roses is he's trying to be hundred at
his temperature he's trying he's seeing
his absolutely a star bid my you is to
pick you up from school
everyone's gonna be in all of that beard
right questions sweetie you're fired
remember to get your voice heard in our
poll or in the comment section below and
tell us who you think argue their case
better and if you enjoy this episode of
vs. make sure you hit that subscribe
button as we'll have new episodes of the
show every Wednesday thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next one
[Music]
you